i ragazzi tutti già mamma diciamo grazie
siamo partiti in quest'arco questo video
così subito perché ricordate che mio
compiuta si apre e si chiude fa bordello
la hp mi ha inviato questo che il nuovo
home enix che non si legge o meno ma se
legge o men e adesso lo de scatoli amo
con il babbo che mi aiutate a portarlo
in macchina perché io peso o meno della
scatola quindi non avrei mai potuto ma
lo faccio io
abbiamo un cavo di dubbia provenienza
elettrico elettrico elettrico un foglio
elettrico sgabello che comodino non le
va beh ma presto orto aspetto aspetta
che questo qui peso e io peso di meno di
questo processo ma non ce la fai a fare
una valori forza di unboxing iscrivetevi
mi piace e dopo ore di intenso montaggio
di computer sono riuscito a politiche
deve sembrare che l'ho montato york e
sono faccio per classica e dopo ore di
intenso montaggio che mi ha impiegato
ben quattro ore in questo pomeriggio
stato anche un pò un casino proprio
tutto monta c'è insomma ho dovuto
mettere tutti i cavi cavi e delle
alimentazione va bene se ci calcolo ci
fosse non si accende lamentazione
domestica e l'alimentazione e poi il
computer cervo controllato che avesse il
si raffredda il sistema di
raffreddamento liquido per evitare il
surriscaldamento
ho dovuto raffreddare il computer
quest'anno non c'è bisogno della loro di
natale non c'è bisogno di farlo per
questo motivo qua che finissimo che
coleman posso cambiare il colore del
computer tipo cambiare il rosso in verde
incredibilmente mancando il punto che è
questo perfetto va bene ragazzi allora
proviamo a fare subito un test visto che
lo acceso ha tra l'altro è andato anche
le cuffie né provare a fare
questa cosa nel migliore dei modi ho
avviato gta 5 con la grafica porca eva
l'ombra si è vista fin qua fantastico ho
avviato ragazzi gta 5 per provare l'ho
messo i dettagli ovviamente al massimo
esagerati per provare la veste grafica è
vero che esista quindi ragazzi
proviamoci almeno destro il computer
salve però era vostro tagliaerba sono
riuscito a incastro credere sono
riusciti a incastrare la macchina su un
tagliaerba non ho parole veramente
maghetti a perché ovviamente salve non
si faccia i servi che in questo momento
non mi sembra il caso non venga qua
venga qua scappiamo a veloci barca che
sono tutto scarso io vado avanti da
quant'è che non ci gioca gta su
scarsissimo perfetto in teoria ragazzi
si arrivò a cinque stelle dovrebbero
appunto arrivare i militari perché
questa mode oltre che aggiungere la
grafica la grafica bella più bella
aggiunge anche i militari alle 5 stelle
quindi in teoria o questa mi piace non
fermi tutti salve ho detto salve quando
io dico saperti riformare si prendono un
po questo volevo questo volevamo donna
madonna
proviamo a fare la cosa che mi riesce
meglio in questo videogame sky fallo
non so perché ragazzo non aveva fermi a
primo tentativo devo farlo al primo
tentativo me lo sento me lo sento
gli olo cannone pirotecnico cosa vuol
dire che non è però ai fuochi
d'artificio
non posso sparare è vietato sparare i
fuochi d'artificio
dov'è la democrazia quando c'era obama
era tutto meglio
buon natale
duccio facchini 10 10 ecco non riesce
non riesce più ma eccolo qua eccolo qua
questo volevo santa monica maledetta
comunque se riuscisse arriva dio
oddio ci ho fatto un video io su quelle
montagne russe salvo salvo ma cosa
bellissima sta roba è geniale regalo
sempre adorata nvidia sta cosa siano
nate a sole gente signora tutto a posto
le auguro buona giornata che c'è non
avevo intenzione di spararle perché
pensate sempre male perche dovete 11
sparata anch'io sotto ponte quando è
andato a los angeles provare l'arma era
finta credo spero poteva oltre a casa ho
visto a stimati offesa al massimo 5
stelle ragazzi ci siamo se arrivo a
dovrebbero arrivare in teoria inibita in
cos'è sta roba hanno sempre fatto così
tipi di gta nostro sera e già la moto è
questa quindi io che funziona perfetta
orca vacca salve
non avevo vista mi scusi ok no sono una
volta sono scemo porca vacca pesoli for
parkour sono un idiota va bene va bene
anche se per poco l'abbiamo vista la
slot e quello l'importante
salve cosa è successo
[Musica]
ma vi faccio così paura solo perché sono
nero razziste cosa ha fatto o non fatto
il numero ho fatto niente
hai versato un buon caffè di starbucks
questo che drift a con la smart tutto
scemo ken block
mi scusi è gesù scramble natale anche a
lei però perché mi state seguendo guarda
che questa la mia macchina voi non lo
sapete è il momento di farvi vedere la
mia abilità di guida su questo gioco che
sono leggenda ormai dovete togliere o
verniciato l'auto nel mentre ma che lei
contratto è stato sapevo che sarei morto
prima o poi del one night day from this
is the way ai rimorchi ti volevo dire
questa esatto a voi dovete capire
ragazzi che per meno sky falling sto
gioco è tutto io farei solo skyfall cioè
stupendo quindi dove teatro due siamo a
no hanno fatto nel punto sbagliato
malissimo
va beh posso andare in città così ma se
io sono superman chi se ne fotte arrivo
in città lo stesso i machete ragazzi in
buon sta cosa quanto dovrebbe essere
[ __ ] posso fare posso superare la
collina così c'era un alce ho visto un
agevolando ragazzi sono un uomo contento
niente sono arrivati in città per i alla
fine sono più comodo di un taxi sono
arriva da dove mi son la è un ora che
sto cadendo cos'è sta roba
sono riuscito ad arrivare all'aeroporto
cadendo vi dico solo questo non c'è il
paracadute sono scemo ce l'avevo non ci
sono un deficiente se ce l'avevo non ce
l'avevo schiaccia prima porca vacca
laida ok franklin non so disse in corso
nei primi regali lo perdesse da
recuperare no grazie
non è vicino porca eva che facciata
fortissimo non arrivare all'aeroporto
quindi lo faccio un'altra volta è una
scusa per farlo tante volte che mi
diverto no vado questo schiva e vabbè li
mortacci tua
no sono scemo avevano anche volare salve
anch'io sto tornando ad esso ma che
coincidenza porca vacca ma non posso
ok ragazzi sono riuscito a mettere il
paracadute per grazia di dio perché non
riusciva a trovare usati o lo prendono
petto ma cosa valga e non mi fai neanche
il planet è come adesso sono caduto così
c'è limite
allora ragazzi non mi ricordo più però
se dovessi andare a cercare ecco niente
a posto che mi ricordavo dover al jet
prova velo trovato è però non è bello se
non mi segue la polizia ma faccio possa
rubare questo non per farmi seguire se
non passò davanti un attimo alla
stazione di polizia col getto privato è
vi faccio vedere poi scappo via ho
rubato questo oggetto guardatemi sono un
criminale io tutto cattivo niente non mi
cagano però non è tanto come pilota del
jet ma devo riuscire a fare una roba che
fisicamente ragazzi è impossibile ma io
atterrerò sulla torre più alta col jazz
non chiedetemi come mai opposto a stento
c atterrò un elicottero vi dico solo
questo però ce l'ha fatta
posso farlo sentono sento non sento
lento lento lento
beh non è andata neanche tanto male la
mia arma preferita in assoluto visto
gioco ma poco in assoluto il cannone
rotaie bellissimo parte viene di una
figata incredi ma a parte quello troppo
preciso leva un sacco
ciao ragazzi è stato incredibile star ma
veramente lanciamissili può accompagnare
solo salve
niente lei è morta per cause naturali va
bene così signora l'aiuto io a rialzarsi
niente cadono le macchine addosso povera
crista non ha fatto niente
no non ricaricare fermo fermo che dovrei
caricati che adesso puoi giocare
no quanto sono storto mammamia ubriachi
simo niente non c'è verso assieme a tre
stelle dai è abbastanza per i non farti
butta giù dall'elicottero possibilmente
grazie se riuscissi a partire magari
entro oggi sarebbe una bella cosa sai
cosa sarebbe una bella cosa sta
succedendo partico quest'aereo la nostra
gola sono pelato a nola macchine hanno
messo il casco aggio giusto metti il
casco in questi momenti perché serve
bravo pirla bravo compri no scusi guarda
ho messo il casco se potrebbe aspettare
un attimo a farmi decollare brutto
idiota no deve passare il cambiare
adesso deve passare ce l'ho fatta
ce l'ho fatta luca luca non ha preso non
è riuscita
magari se guardo avanti un'idea che dite
prima si può fermare l'aereo di linea
porca vacca laio veramente nuova non
volevo ma è bastato un colpo
ragazzi se devo decollare devo ricordare
veloce veloce veloce veloce veloce e
vabbè non ce la fornisce la francia
ormai non ce la farò mai
ormai mi farò mai forse ce la faccio
forse se dio vuole parti e parti porca
vacca come una sua vista brutta
io direi che per questa volta basta non
so se esistono altri modi
che aumentano la grecia è applicato per
vedere se riesco a fare la grafica a
rendere la grafica migliore questa si
chiamava reds
il problema è che problema è che non
vedo i palazzi cimino dovrei prendere la
patente tra un po pesante ma dai ragazzi
lascio perdere va bene così no problem
jolo viva la vita per questo video vi
sia piaciuto è stato alquanto strano
però va bene quindi ragazzi sparavieri
sia piaciuto cosi vissuto un momento non
mi piace anche a persone di facebook
come lottatore descrizione sortite ci
vediamo al prossimo video vedo ragazzi
[Musica]